[Music]
allow me to tell you the classic
children's tale of Chicken Little
otherwise known as Henny Penny as the
tale goes little Henny was outside one
day when an acorn fell from a tree and
hit her on the head because of her
naivete and simplemindedness Henny
foolishly began to believe that the sky
itself was falling down around her she
spent the rest of the day trying to
convince others like goosey loosey and
turkey-lurkey that the sky was most
certainly falling and the world was
surely coming to an end in most versions
of the story the trip does not end well
for Henny and her hysterical friends
after they meet the sly Foxy Loxy I
don't want to give everything away
though so either read the story for
yourself or check out the classic season
6 episode of The Golden Girls in which
they reenact the tale I mention Henny
and Lucy and Turkey and foxy not just
because they're great names to say but
because it seems that just about
everyone is telling us the sky is
falling these days between Trump Russia
North Korea we've got about half the
country that's in total freakout mode
every day this freak out takes on a new
urgency one day the world is ending
because America left the Paris climate
Accord another day it's because of the
net neutrality reversal and another day
it's because Trump holds his water glass
with two hands this endless hysteria is
not only being amplified by the media
but it's actually being poked and
prodded by them as well
blue cheque verified journalists on
Twitter who work for news organizations
which really are nothing more than
partisan activist outlets want to keep
you clicking on their articles and
videos and they know that the best way
to do that is to convince you that not
only is the sky falling but it's gonna
land directly on your head what if and
just hear me out on this one
this outrage Factory is completely wrong
and the world isn't coming to an end
just yet crazy I know but I think that
it actually might be true this doesn't
mean that things are perfect but they
are pretty damn good this is the
position of my guest this week Harvard
psychology professor Steven Pinker
Pinker argues despite our world of
perceived horror and chaos people are
living longer happier healthier and
freer
lives right now more than any other time
in human history this doesn't mean we
don't have work to do but if we don't
stop and smell the roses we might toss
away all the goodness humans have
created for the prospect of a utopia
that will never appear this is why I'm
so proud of the work we've done here on
the Rubin report I truly believe that
the conversations were having are at
least some part of the antidote to the
craziness right now if those of us who
care about enlightenment principles like
science reason and natural rights can
make our voices louder than this cliff
we seem to be about to go off of might
just turn into a bridge to a better
world Henny Penny story took a drastic
turn when she met Foxy Loxy who tricked
her and her friends to go to his lair
well in real life we've got a Wolf
Blitzer in a Situation Room if the sky
is falling maybe just changing the
channel is all we have to do to survive
the day joining me today is a Johnstone
family professor in the Department of
Psychology at Harvard University as well
as a New York Times bestselling author
whose new book enlightenment now is for
sale right now Steven Pinker welcome to
the Rubin report thank you I am I am
thrilled to have you here I think I have
emailed or called or contacted or pigeon
messaged everyone related to you or that
knows you in any way to get you here and
here I am right here you worked it goes
to prove that a little positivity I
think can make some things happen so
true yeah all right lot I want to talk
to you about I thought before we dive
into the book and and all the the things
that you teach and write about and all
that I just I like hearing a little bit
about people's history and where they
come from and growing up and all that
you are Canadian and I've had a lot of
Canadians on lately I find there's
something about Canadians in general
that I like what is it about Canadians
that leads to a certain Pleasant
disposition well we're so reasonable or
so yea polite yeah sometimes people say
think the motto of Canada is peace order
and good government yes and it's a
country that is that has been diverse
for for quite some time
Quebec where I grew up has
english-speaking community in a
french-speaking community and we've we
didn't begin with a revolution unlike
the United States negotiated our way to
independence we were part of the British
Empire in the British Commonwealth and
kind of have that British Reserve and
politeness yeah so that we have we have
some things going for us
couple of things going for yeah at least
until at least all the Americans end up
moving up there if things keep going
this way although we might build a wall
yeah all right you guys may end up
building the wall exactly tell me a
little bit about growing up your family
what kind of family you grew up in I I
grew up in the english-speaking section
of Montreal it was pretty segregated
when I grew up I grew up in a Jewish
english-speaking community which was
known for producing among others Leonard
Cohen who is a contemporary of my
mother's mhm the author Mordecai Richler
who was a contemporary of my father's
William Shatner Burt Bacharach Wow the
Saul Bellow status versus childhood in
Montreal so it's a small community that
has a number of people that were proud
of yeah what do you make of that that so
many I mean that's a pretty diverse
interesting group of people right there
and I'm sure there are others yeah I it
it may just be that having many cultural
influences both Canada's really cut
dominated by the United States it really
is the 800-pound gorilla next door yeah
so is the American influence the British
influence the French influence perhaps
is just being in a cosmopolitan diverse
community not helped with that and of
course the the Jewish influence although
it was not I didn't grow up and none of
the people that I mentioned grew up in
an ultra-orthodox community high grew up
in Oulu in Agra with a reformed temple
we didn't take God all that seriously
but we did take Jewish identity
seriously yeah I don't remember a moment
in which I decided oh I'm an atheist I
just was not a big issue one way or
another do you find that to be sort of a
standard thing with most secular Jews I
think that's sort of at least the ones
that I've been talking to on this show
that
think are sort of out there more that
seems to be a thing that there's an
ethnic identity or a cultural identity
that's separate from the belief part
absolutely and I think that's more true
of Judaism than it is of say Catholicism
where the belief really is stipulated in
Judaism is a bit of a kind of Don't Ask
Don't Tell as long as you have a thought
as long as we pay the laws and rituals
right if you keep the Sabbath if you
have you know mats on Passover then
you're a good Jew and what you believe
is just not as important what one rabbi
said to my wife rebecca goldstein
another secular Jew mmm well known a
secular humanist writer when she talked
about her novel 36 arguments for the
existence of God a work of fiction which
is kind of a great and she spoke at a
Jewish Community Center and I was a
little worried whether there'd be some
pushback from the rabbi who introduced
her own afterwards he went over he said
you know there's nothing in Judaism that
says you have to believe in God you just
can't believe in more than one of them
that's I mean that's pretty perfect you
think there's a there's an inherent
problem they're sort of disconnecting
God from reason if it really is well
just for the longevity of it let's say
oh yeah yeah it's a good question I
think that may have been part of the
explanation for why I mean there's so
many secular Jewish intellectuals kind
of immersed in argument dispute ation
particularly about morals and ethics but
without a but it was all argument
disputation it wasn't a catechism that
you had to recite it wasn't a set of
beliefs that you I have to have so there
was a tradition of disputation that's
what the rabbi's were famous for right
at the pill pull the hair splitting and
and maybe that was a contributor as well
but I went to public schools I went and
in fact when you go to public schools in
Quebec when I in my childhood met you
had two Protestant schools because it
was divided along religious lines they
were Protestant schools and Catholic so
history singing Protestant meant I'm
Catholic basically everyone else yeah
putting the Muslims and the Jews and
Chinese and so on there's a bizarre
system yeah how's how he just hadn't lis
unconstitutional in this country and I
got I got I actually got a pretty
serious Protestant religious education I
sang hymns we said the Lord's Prayer
every day I learned about
for Jesus so they had the Jews in the
Muslims and everyone I mean yeah in the
getting a Protestants yeah and at one
point I remember I was you know eight or
nine in my and I absolutely didn't even
belong to a temple I said so it's my
mother one of my friends said that that
Jews aren't supposed to believe in Jesus
my should I not believe in Jesus anymore
he sent me their Hebrew school so fast I
made my head spin hilarious and my
teachers because they couldn't hire
Catholic teachers either and virtually
everyone in Quebec is among the
francophone community are Catholics it's
actually hired Algerian and Tunisian and
moroccan jews to teach French to the
Jewish and Protestant kids of Montreal
the parson Kizza Montreal did not learn
French from native québécois we learned
it from Egyptian and Tunisian immigrants
I thought it was I'm pretty sure I know
the subject of your next book I mean it
sounds like there's just so much
richness just in that or at least
there's a little comedy in there so I
think it sounds like your family was
kind of on the intellectual side or at
least that the county was red house was
full of books and magazines my my father
was had a law degree but didn't practice
when I was a child he was a and handled
some little bit of real estate did sales
before starting a law practice pretty
late in life my mother was like most
mothers of the 50s and 60s a homemaker
but then found a career when she was
kind of getting bored when it became a
guidance counselor and then a vice
principal of a high school and and my
mother Roslyn Pinker very intellectual
an intense reader knows everything
intellectually very engaged yeah and my
sister Susan is a columnist for The Wall
Street Journal certain have been a
couple of books went on sex differences
one on face to face contact my brother
Rob I worked for the Canadian government
for several decades as a policy analyst
and
an administrator so how much of the
intellectual pursuits that you all have
do you think is is biological versus
just learned experience yeah this is one
of the themes that keeps coming up
around these conversations and then it
is was a topic of my book the blank
slate in the modern denial of human
nature yeah the blank slate being the
metaphor that I argued became kendama
Natan intellectual life largely for
political reasons yeah can you explain
that a little bit for the people that
don't know the book yeah so the the
blank slate the modern denial of human
nature just was released in 2016 with an
afterword was about the idea that that
there is no such thing as human nature
that we are blank slates written on by
our parents by by the culture by
education and that there's no innate
human traits or ways of learning and
thinking it's it's you can program a
human however you want and I agree that
it was popular in the 20th century for
political reasons one of them being that
it seems like the ultimate way to
achieve equality you know for all zero
then zero equals zero equals zero and so
we all have to be equal right
I already this is a mistake in the book
that equality is really a legal and
moral principle to treat everyone
equally it's not really the belief that
we're all clones room like slates
and a lot of the book tried to both lay
out the science of human nature but also
to explore the political and emotional
and moral baggage and coloring and to
try to clarify it and so the difference
between equality of treatment and
equality of of our biological endowment
was a major theme that also of course
enters into discussion of sex
differences to where one of the reasons
that certain intellectual factions
certain parts of feminism want to deny
that there are any sex differences they
think well that will make it impossible
to discriminate because there's nothing
to discriminate them on we're all
exactly this born exactly the same right
and I do that's a big big mistake
there's first of all there is a lot of
evidence that men and women aren't
identical in all traits yeah I mean I'm
not a scientist but I
I think there is a lot of everything I
think anyone who's had a son and a
daughter has been in a heterosexual
relationship yeah anyone who's listened
to gossip about anyone talking about
anyone else yeah men and women aren't
really not this is not exactly the same
but I think the myth that they're the
same was introduced for political
purposes namely that would make
discrimination irrational right because
there's no nothing to discriminate on
and I argue that that you know that's
just a error in logic I strongly believe
in gender equity that no one should be
prejudged because they're a man or a
woman partly because of a scientific
fact that there's a huge overlap between
the sexes in any trait you want to look
at so you can't predict an individual's
traits just knowing that they're a man
or a woman but they the policy we should
be fair doesn't require the false belief
that were the same that we are single
what's the best have you heard any
argument for that belief that you
thought made any sense or you just for
which belief or the idea that that this
that these genders are equal like when
that windy because you must hear this
from other academics right I mean we
know that some of this stuff is being
taught at schools yeah well there are
you know there's no doubt that there are
there's a normal enormous overlap
there's no doubt and and some of the
differences between the sexes are pretty
small and and subtle so in say
mathematical ability which was one of
the most controversial claims about sex
differences it it could it went to a
huge firestorm when Larry Summers the
president of Harvard mentioned that
differences between the sexes might
explain why the number of engineering
professors at Harvard and MIT work
wasn't 50/50 down the line male/female
yeah
this is very much like the the James
d'amour situation with with Google it is
exactly I mean it's almost it's almost a
replay yeah and and it isn't easy in
fact it would be hard to say that men
and women are better at math in general
it's you have to even drill down to
certain sub components like mentally
rotating three-dimensional objects that
men are clearly better at but women are
better at word problems in arithmetic
and math so it's a so some of the
pushback is that in fact the science is
often complicated
you can't make us sweeping across the
board generalization yeah and then the
other kind of pushback for people who
defend the blank slate is well yeah
that's true of you know 2002 when your
book came out but society is changing
and you know more women are consuming
porn and more women are having multiple
sexual partners and maybe the difference
is saying sexuality aren't due to human
nature but just due to our culture at a
particular moment that may become
obsolete that seems incredibly dangerous
to me to view it that way
well maybe although you know you could
in some ways it's actually highly
progressive and even correct because you
could have said you know 70 years ago
women you don't want to go into the
professions they they want to stay home
with the kids and housework and that's
what makes them complete and satisfied
and happy and they'll be all you know
neurotic and anxious if they start to
become lawyers and doctors and we know
from the course of history that you know
if that's not true that when as soon as
the doors open women did pour through
the doors and so that would be an
example where too strong a claim of
biological differences would have been
refuted by the facts of history so it's
not a slam dunk I mean it is something
that has to be examined on a
case-by-case basis are you shocked at
how difficult it is to talk about all of
this without getting yourself yourself
or any of the people that talk about it
into hot water yeah because the amount
of nuance that you have to go through
here as I can see you're you're quite
well-versed at you're probably the best
at it it's a lot to make sure that
somebody can't pinpoint that one line
but then they're gonna just you know
drag you for exactly right well and the
reason that I wrote the blank slate was
it wasn't so much I have a chapter on
gender but the point wasn't just to
review the literature on gender
differences it was also to say okay so
what how does it matter for our public
debates mhm
and I also documented in the book how
even when the book first came out there
was a history of people being deep
platformed and shouted down and called
you know all kinds of nasty names for
for the view that were not blank slates
and I said well look this is based on on
emotion based on bad politics not based
on the facts so I kind of I don't know
if I'm gonna say defended myself but
I've laid out all of these political
controversies so I wasn't blundering
into it naive I was actually that was
actually the subject of the book right
sometimes though that that can't fully
defend you there all right and in fact
both Larry Summers and Jamie d'amour
yeah they almost could have taken their
speeches and in case of Larry Summers
partly did from the chapter on gender in
the book so I managed to escape some
trouble that people who then repeated
the arguments got into trouble for yeah
so it's interesting you sort of laid out
a case beforehand to defend yourself you
did like sort of a preemptive strike
exactly where someone both of those guys
I know James I know James personally
needs been in here or it's like he sort
of stumbled into this thing and then the
the reaction the way it sorted out it
just becomes this bigger beast that you
end up fighting when you were just
really trying to talk about science well
the science I I wasn't just talking
about the science cuz I was talking
about first the science then what are
the political and moral implications
which I thought got confused
feeding back on people trying to
shoehorn the science into a politically
correct position because they were kind
of lazy when it came to the politics you
know I don't believe in I obviously I
don't believe in discrimination against
anyone and but the point being that
having that belief doesn't mean that you
have to insist that were blank slates
right and I made that argument for other
controversies around human nature like
do we have any violent impulses where
there's there there's a kind of
political argument for a different
reason maybe people think well if we're
innately violent then we're kind of
doomed to war and forever and if you try
to reduce war you're just some romantic
peace Nick and it's hopeless and war is
in human nature therefore since war is
bad
and if we're violent then we'll always
have war we can't be violent and I argue
that's that too is illogical we do have
violent impulses I think that's pretty
clear
but it's not all we have we also have
how
the Faculty of self-control we also have
empathy we have cognitive processes of
problem-solving so we can figure out how
that we can reduce war we've got moral
norms they're just certain things you
don't do and the fact that part of us is
violent doesn't mean we're doomed to
violence because part of us pushes back
on the violence I cited a statistic that
three-quarters of men and 60% of women
at least once have had a homicidal
fantasy imagined killing something they
don't like three-quarters of men and 60%
oh yeah and and when I introduced this
factor lecturer and I say well what does
this tell us about human nature tells us
that three-quarters of men are liars but
but I point at this this doesn't mean
that trying to increase peace is futile
because there are other parts of human
nature we can work with and of course
that was what led to my more recent book
the better angels of our nature and they
said not only is it possible it's
happened yeah but again that it's kind
of the the nexus between the political
on the one hand and the scientific on
the other that I was exploring and I
talked about how the people who thought
they were advocates of peace tried to
squash all evidence that people have
violent impulses because it's just
politically too uncomfortable and I said
that's first of all distorting the
science is never a good idea and is it
clear about the politics then the
science doesn't even mean that we've got
to accept war yeah so for someone that
sort of insulated themselves from some
of this because you were doing the work
beforehand which is actually pretty
brilliant tactic are you afraid that the
hard sciences are going to be hit by all
of this identity politics stuff in a
bigger way than we're seeing right now
when it comes to to gender or race or
any of these issues it's not even so
much the hard sciences but the social
sciences well we know the social
sciences yeah how'd it happen hit yeah
but you don't fear that it's gonna come
for the hard sciences too well there may
be some aspects of genetics and brain
science that are that if they're feeling
the political pressure the neuroscience
of sex differences for example they
certainly the genetics of
intelligence and personality have felt
that political pressure yeah one of my
collaborators and former students James
Lee presented a paper where he's part of
a consortium that for the first time
identified a number of genes that were
linked to intelligence I mean there's no
IQ gene but there are hundreds many
growing or thousands of genes that that
could bump your IQ up by a fraction of a
point up or down mm-hmm and they mean
some of the first really hard replicable
discoveries because there are a lot of
bogus discoveries in the past but
their's was really solid and there was
there was a pretty big pushback
including from the president of the
Society saying this is this is fascist -
this is unacceptable so there was some
pushback and this was this was genetics
yeah so what do you make of the people
that focus on like race and IQ I you
know I've had stefan molyneux here I
don't know if you know who is but he
really focuses on that and I wanted what
I wanted to know from him really was not
necessarily why it really not what do
you think of this but why the focus on
that yeah that seemed to me that's the
part I'm more concerned about yeah I
think it's a I think it's an excellent
question and it's one that that torments
me I mean on the one hand you could make
the argument well we should not be
afraid of the truth and for that matter
a vigorous exploration of the genetics
of racial differences might show that
there are no genetic differences
relevant to personality or intelligence
and that would give races of a really
decisive blow yeah the other hand you
never know that before you look right so
you can't count on that you of course if
you do science you've got to be prepared
for any possibility there is I think a
legitimate question of whether we really
should be getting to the bottom of this
it's an argument actually goes back to
my old MIT colleague Noam Chomsky way
back in the 1970s said we can't insist
that the truth be one way or another
because that's just contrary to a whole
spirit of science but we don't have to
ask every question a lot of questions
that are scientifically pretty minor
they could have socially damaging
consequences so let's put them really
low on the list and he suggested that
that race and IQ
for example is should not be of interest
in a society that treats people as
individuals because then it's just like
a correlation between any two traits and
that that we should just be a low
priority and something we should ignore
now that's a little bit I think it
ignores the fact that there are people
who already are dividing humans by race
and by and measuring the outcomes and
attributing it to poverty or racism and
then you kind of say well gee if as long
as we're raising the question at all
should we look at all the hypotheses it
might even be an argument for just
downplaying race in general instead of
dividing us up by race and obsessively
measuring the differences look at things
like class and income mm-hmm because
that that's really what what matters
more and just not make everything a
racial issue in the first place so that
whether the racial issue is from biology
kind of fades in importance yeah you
mentioned the Nexus of politics and
science I really like that phrase
because I think as so many of the
conversations I'm having here it seems
to me that politics and science are
really just linked all the time it
explains why so many people want to talk
to you and why they want to talk to the
Weinstein brothers and Sam Harris and so
many other people are you a little
concerned that it's becoming so
political yeah I mean I mean part of the
it is that it's that what but what I'm
doing and what some of the other your
other guests have been doing is to try
to deep alit aside some of the
scientific issues and that's certainly
what I tried to do in the blank slate or
you clarify what what the political
issues are yeah and no but it's almost
impossible these days right it is
becoming a little bit well it's it the
landscape is really diverse and divided
I mean there are they vary the identity
politicians and the social justice
warriors and the political correctness
police who are kind of making things as
political as possible they've been
around for a long time when I was a
student in the 70s there were plenty of
people who are shouting things like
fascists don't have the right to speak
or chanting mobs that shut down and my
Harvard colleague Neil Wilson when he
published sociobiology this isn't a new
thing mm-hmm and there are certainly
constituencies that are totally opened
to D politicizing the science and
considering the politics on its own
terms but on the other hand there is a
fringe that appears to be more radical
than ever yeah how do you decide how
much weight that fringe has that seems
to be one of the themes these days it
seems to be very hard to tell is this
just this small group that's screaming a
lot or or has it truly infected not only
a ton of you know the millennial
generation and a huge swath of young
people but that also it does seem to be
creeping up or creeping down depending
on which way you look at it a ton of
academics at universities and all sorts
of all sorts of other people that that
actually have power well I think the
academics have been distorted for quite
some time and this is a an idea that's
been pushed by Jonathan Hite tetlock
Jose Duarte shot a lot of stern they had
a pretty widely discussed article called
that the title somewhere viewpoint
diversity will help social science where
they gave a number of cases some of
which I had discussed in in the blank
slate of how just the questions that
psychologists asked the the items they
put on their questionnaires the way they
frame issues just clearly has a
left-wing bias that they argued that if
there were also people conservatives in
more of them insight departments then
they would have pointed out hey your
questionnaire is flawed right and that
the actual quality the science would
improved and to the credit of my field
of psychology their paper was published
there in a journal where there were 30
commentaries so 30 people had a chance
to go after them or teams and it was it
was there was disagreement but was very
respectful they weren't called any nasty
names and it was a really good debate
but the the question that you asked
about how is this a are the the totally
illiberal and radical movements the ones
that that just shout down speakers
sometimes physically assault them is
that the whole millennial generation or
is that just a
increasingly vocal fringe my mind was
changed just a couple of days ago when I
read an article in Fox about a new study
Sam Harris had sent it to me saying that
actually support for free speech is
increasing including the article you saw
the article yeah okay so that you know
that I wasn't I was kind of surprised I
wasn't totally shocked yes at least my
experience at Harvard is that the
students are all the ones that I've
interacted with admittedly a biased
sample but they are perfectly supportive
of debate free speech openness so it's
interesting so I mentioned right before
we started that I spoke at Harvard
through the open oh yes right and it was
a wonderful group and I and it was clear
that they were politically diverse and
and all the other diversity that
everyone likes but that I don't care
about that much but afterwards we we
went to a dinner and there were about
thirty or forty kids I was with Brett
Weinstein actually and I asked them like
what do you guys do you are you guys
okay
saying what you think and do you think
it's gonna hurt your grades or hurt your
friendship and virtually everyone said
yes so I'm still struggling with this
because I didn't they said they said yes
that it would either hurt them or
they've lost friends I mean mostly I
sense most of them were kind of
libertarian ish kind of live and let
live fun but certainly not all of them
but but virtually everyone at the table
said that they either were afraid to say
certain things to friends or certainly
to professor's so that's why when I read
the articles like that at Vox and I go
to these campuses and I hear this
consistently it's just hard to grade and
I and that's exactly why I'm posing the
question to him yeah it's just hard to
this way this article was was
eye-opening and it went against the
narrative that the millennial generation
are a bunch of snowflakes they're a
bunch of you know of cultural
revolutionaries the Warriors it's just
that that it there certainly is that
faction but it may not characterize our
era altogether yeah have you thought at
all about how much social media is a
piece of this puzzle well I don't know
and that's the nowadays everything is
blamed on social media like you know
what the role of El Nino and then
that was on myspace yeah right yeah I
don't know a lot of this I think
predated social media I think that cable
news networks had had a role Fox News in
particular because it was so politicized
in a way that no previous network really
had been and and there are studies
showing that when a town gets Fox News
and you could do the natural experiment
because some towns got it before others
just because the way cable companies
offer different packages for no
particular reason you could tell the
town's the god Fox News became more
polarized and became and shifted to the
right well so really did have a causal
effect that's one case where it's not
just correlational yeah so you you had a
strange moment about a month or two ago
about two months ago now where you you
said something to the effect you someone
asked you a question at a panel about
the all right and and in effect you said
I don't want to put words mouth what did
you say
this is best I don't want to butcher
open campus initiative oh it was it
there okay there you go so I know this
is a good group of people you were
sitting with it was of the and the topic
of the event was did political correct
correctness help elect Trump
it was held almost on the anniversary of
the 16 election and I suggested that I
thought it did in part because the when
you have certain ideas that are just not
discussable on on campus and you've got
a savvy interconnected community as the
original alt right were a lot of people
associate cult right with the torch
carrying skinheads but I had a mind was
the term as it originally applied to
Internet discussion groups mm-hmm and
that the the danger of restricting
debate on a campus of making certain
ideas taboo is that when smart people do
stumble upon them then they number one
are completely alienated from the
mainstream intellectual life because
they think well this is a truth that
they can't handle what other truths
can't and they since the ideas never get
expressed the kind of pushback and and
contextualization and counter-arguments
kind of thing that you that you want for
any idea never happens and within this
like-minded community they sometimes
jump to the most extreme conclusions so
it's sort of a self-fulfilling prophecy
of sewers yeah so an example being
gender differences if it's taboo even to
mention the possibility that men and
women differ then you stumble across
some pretty good scientific evidence
that they do then you might be like you
know Milo your novel is saying oh we
should we should have fewer women in
medical school because they're just
gonna drop out and have babies now I
mean it's a totally you know idiotic
idea but the reason that he could put
forward an idiotic idea is that since
the whole existence of sex differences
never discuss never said that's my
idiotic idea yeah and likewise and there
are a number of other facts that are
undiscussables
take two extreme conclusions if you're
not challenged whereas if you bring them
out into the open then you you can put
them into perspective sunlight is the
best disinfectant in many cases it is
another example is that that rates of
crime differ between blacks and whites
now if that's a fact that's almost none
discussable but just go to fbi.gov look
up they break down rates of crime by age
by race by state and you know there it
is now if you have never even noticed
that then you can say oh gee I wonder if
you know african-americans are you know
innately more violent than well I
thought that's completely wrong because
we know that no two ethnic groups ever
have the same crime rate and they can
shift over time it used to be the Irish
that were the that had sky high rates of
violence compared to the non Irish and
we know that that vanished over time and
the black/white difference might as well
but that second fact namely ethnic and
racial differences are ubiquitous and
they can change the time will never even
get mentioned if the mere fact that
there is a difference is unmentionable
in the first place so that was my
argument yeah I gave some other examples
anyway that was then there's a doctored
film clip on some alt-right sites saying
OC Pinker's saying with the alt writers
you know is correct actually saying how
can we you know how can we starve the
author right
right however we're we're feeding them
inadvertently right you you were
basically I mean just for the layman
that's watching this I mean you were
basically saying allow for more
information so that those bad ideas
won't be able to flourish I mean that is
that sort of 101 version that was the
whole point exactly yeah and it was it
was a edited to leave out that parts and
then the kind of regressive left picked
up on it to also suggest that I was
sympathetic to the alt right which is no
bizarre attribution you could imagine
and indeed enlightenment now has a whole
chapter on why the the author right is
has gone off the off the rails
so unfortunately this misconception
after a couple of after you know but a
day was corrected both in the New York
Times and in The Guardian I in England I
may they came to my defense and set
things right but it was a bizarre
episode of how as The Times put it
social media makes you stupid
yeah precisely all right so I do want to
spend our whole second okay talking
about the book but very quickly just
when you dealt with that whole thing I
mean I remember reading it and I think
there was something in an odd way
I think the REIT would the reaction
between as you said the regressive left
and the alright that they were sort of
teaming up on you again yeah I guess it
I thought that it was in a weird way
even though I know it probably
personally for you is no fun and you
probably had all sorts of people saying
terrible things to you and and all of
that that I thought if anyone has read
any of Stephens books or even remotely
knows what this guy is doing that I
think I don't know what you consider
yourself politically you strike me as
sort of just an old-school liberal I
don't want to under that if he's
centrist moderate I have I have
sympathies to different policies and but
yeah I'm pretty eclectic and centrist
yeah so that that basically I thought
this guy is so obviously just decent and
coming at this from from a scientific
perspective that if this is what they're
gonna do
where at where you say one line yeah
this is going to just I mean really my
feeling was it could destroy like the
fabric of society really if we just
start picking off everybody and I've
seen a lot of instances of this and this
is you know when I've talked to when
I've talked to de Moura I've talked to
Brett Weinstein or Lindsey Shepherd from
Laurier up and
and a few others that they but I thought
yours was just such an example of this
is so ridiculous yes well so perhaps
there was a nice push back to it maybe
and that was exactly the New York Times
response I mean that's why they titled
the op-ed by that jesse single how
social media makes us stupid yeah yeah
all right let's talk about the book
right here in front of me enlightenment
now I've been kicking around this phrase
on Twitter that's called a little
traction that we are now in the unlight
because it seems like we're in this
endless stream of constant stupidity and
some of it seems social media related
and we touched a little bit on that in
part one and when I'm saying it I'm
saying it a little tongue-in-cheek
and actually this book is sort of the
the answer to I think what I'm calling
the Enlightenment that there are so many
good things happening right now and it's
very hopeful and optimistic and I always
tell people I'm an optimist otherwise I
couldn't do this you know I mean I I
feel that we there's a chance we can
make things better so first off let's
just do some one-on-one stuff here what
our enlightenment values to you well I
characterized them in the subtitle a
book as reason science humanism and
progress reason that we should analyze
our situation our predicament using the
most rigorous logic that we can and
rather than relying on Dogma Authority
traditional scripture that's good for
social media for social media although
at least throwing ideas out there is as
long as they get evaluated as long as
they get criticized right science namely
that we should test our hypotheses seek
deep explanations and the science
provides us not just with gadgets and
cures for disease although it's
important that it does that but also
defines our human condition that that
concepts from science like evolution
like entropy like the whole naturalistic
worldview that the laws of nature do
their thing without caring about us
these are things that we have to
understand as the most basic facts about
our existence
so reliance is part has to be part of
our world to you then humanism is the
that it's human beings and other
sentient animals that deserve our moral
concern as opposed to they say the glory
of the tribe or following the carrying
out religious dictates or the faith or
some messianic age that it's just do
people live long healthy happy
stimulating lives that's what we should
care about and promises that if we use
the reason in science to make people
better off well maybe we can gradually
succeed yeah so it's funny when I when I
was reading this and the only word that
like dinged a little something my head
was progress and I think it's partly
because of the way progressives have
used progress that progress in and of
itself you want to progress meaning have
more and more opportunity for people
more and more equality for people I
think that's a far cry from what I think
the progressives are doing right now
because that that's the most subjective
one of any of those terms right well I
have the the wisecrack that progressives
hate progress you look at the people who
denied that we've made progress it's
often the people who politically label
themselves as progressive who can't
stand the idea we've made progress
because they want to say that every
aspect of our current society and
institutions as you know corrupt and
racist and controlled by the by the 1%
and everything is getting worse and
worse and worse
ironically because the whole point of
being a progressive presumably is that
progressive activism is not a waste of
time but it actually brings benefits and
which actually has sort of the catch-22
of progress in general that you have to
acknowledge it but in a weird way you
need to not acknowledge it to keep
furthering it yeah so there is an
optimum amount and one has to keep in
mind the two ideas that we've made
progress but we've got huge challenges
ahead of us and just a very simple
example extreme poverty the bare minimum
that you that you need to feed your
family has been has been falling and
that's it's got to be an example of
progress in a couple of hundred years
ago you could say that probably 90
percent of humanity was lived in extreme
poverty now it's less than ten percent
that's amazing yeah a lot of that
happened just in the last 30 years but
another way of stating the same fact
is that 730 million people live in
extreme poverty now that's the same fact
10% of 7.3 billion 730 million that's an
awful lot of miserable people now those
are the same class then arrived in two
different ways and we got to be able to
think in both ways and let's try to get
it to zero now that's not a crazy
romantic utopian starry-eyed
goal that is one of the UN sustainable
development goals the predecessor the
Millennium Development Goals for poverty
was reached five years ahead of schedule
so the new goal which is to eliminate
extreme poverty everywhere by 2030
probably a little too optimistic but but
not not completely crazy and maybe it'll
be instead of 0% maybe it'll be 2% and
maybe it'll be 2040 but still it's an
amazing aspiration in the first place
yeah how much of this do you think and
this a little bit gets back to the blank
slate but how much of this do you think
the way you view progress whether the
acknowledgement of progress or that you
sort of need to feel that we've made no
progress to kind of fuel yourself how
much of that do you think is just
hardwired and the way we look at the
world I think some of it comes from
certain cognitive biases one of them
being the availability heuristic me
discovered by Daniel Kahneman and Amos
Tversky namely the human mind generally
estimates probability and risk by
calling examples from memory if you've
just seen a tornado on the news then you
think that tornadoes are a major cause
of death and the fact that you know
falls off ladders killed many more
people than tornadoes doesn't register
because those don't make the news and
and we don't net naturally calibrate for
how many opportunities there are for bad
things to happen how big the world is
how many people there are we just
remember the examples and that's what
drives our intuitions and when you have
the news media reporting everything that
goes wrong everywhere then you can come
away with in the impression that the
world is falling apart because all the
parts of the world that aren't falling
apart never make the news yeah that's
one there is also a we we are I think
tuned to dwell on the negative probably
because
and things can hurt you a lot more than
good things can help you so there is
something adaptive in a natural
environment to you know be on the
lookout for what can kill you so that's
just a survival instinct that's I think
it's part of the survival instinct there
are there are other things too like the
there's always implicit competition
between different elites in society the
academics the journalists the
politicians the business people the
religious the military you know they're
all different kind of power centers and
they all kind of compete with each other
for prestige and an influence and if you
say society is declining its corrupt
it's a mess it's horrible
kind of a way of each one of these
groups can kind of feel superior to the
others the academics could say look what
the business managers know the contrary
in a businessman I can say look what the
politicians are doing to the country and
the challengers can say look if the
incumbents are doing and so it's it's
kind of a backhanded way of social
one-upmanship yeah do you sense that
right now we're at a unique position to
bring back more enlightenment values
like it seems to me that because of
Trump because of social media that just
everything is sort of upside down right
now this again has been a theme with a
bunch of I guess that everything is sort
of on the table and that there's great
opportunity we don't know which way it's
gonna go but there's great opportunity
for good ideas there's a great
opportunity for bad ideas obviously I
know which way we're both hoping this is
gonna yes but do you think that we
actually are in a unique moment right
now I know everyone always thinks that
they're always there they're always in
against moment right what do you think
there's something unique right now well
it's this one I think there's kind of
like inequality of a reset of reason
maybe growing that at the top there's so
many areas in which we become so much
more irrational and reasonable like
evidence-based medicine who used to be
your doctor had a hunch and operated on
you gave you a drug and there's no
reason to think they would actually work
and now therapies are a value a to do in
big studies or a data-driven policing
one of the reasons that the crime rate
went down so dramatically starting in
the 90s
is that the police started to gather
block-by-block data and where the
violence was occurring they kind of
collapsed on those areas like a ton of
bricks make sure that you know one gang
member that just suffered a an injury
wouldn't be roaring for revenge saying
you know we're watching you and that
really drove down the rate of crime by a
lot hmm in in sports sabermetrics and
Moneyball much more rational analysis it
is the effective altruism movement how
can we allocate charity and volunteering
so it actually does good as opposed to
just giving people a warm glow so that
all of these areas but at the same time
you get these nutball conspiracy
theories and the fake news and the
politicized denial of science such as
vaccine safety and climate change so the
question is how do we let the standards
of rationality pictures would trickle
down make it so that that it's kind of
second nature for everyone to just not
think in certain ways because they've
just been proven to be obviously
ridiculous yeah how do you do it I mean
I think that that's a good I may not be
the one to you know to change a whole
society I do it by appealing to the kind
of people who watch this show kind of
people who read my books in the hopes
that it will kind of spread out from
there and we know it's not it's not that
it can't happen there are certain bad
ideas that at one point are taken
seriously and then they just drop off
and like no one talks about them ever
again you know like just you know my
lifetime when I was a kid there was a
debate over racial segregation you know
should black students be admitted to
University of Mississippi I mean you
just couldn't have that debate anymore
even among the the farthest right or the
right yeah that's just no longer an
issue should women be allowed to to work
and in earlier decades and centuries it
was slavery or women's suffrage and
superstitions like you know alchemy or
human sacrifice so it's not hopeless
that sometimes what happens is that at
any given time
a range of reasonableness but that that
Center drifts so that some things that
were at the tail end of ridiculousness
even the conspiracy theory mongers and
the most benighted can no longer take it
seriously yeah how much of this is just
sort of our or the discussion around all
this is just about our lack of patience
because actually when the when the
publisher sent me the the book it's an
Enlightenment now and as you can see you
guys had the fun now it's bigger than
enlightenment and I thought that was
kind of interesting because we live in a
time of immediate reaction to everything
and selfies and likes and people just
don't have patience anymore attention
spans are incredibly short that we want
more now but some of these things are
just the long game yes I think that's it
that's exactly right we also we have
amnesia for how things were not so long
ago yeah that's a point that I make
repeatedly even though there are you
know there there's a horrific war going
on now in Syria but we forget some of
the horrific wars that were going on in
the eighties and nineties yeah what can
we do to stop that amnesia cuz I think
that's a big part of this yeah and I
think the culture of journalism should
should put events of the day into some
context now I mean going back to get
hundreds of years the American
Revolution but even just you know what
was like in the 1990s was like the 80s
because likewise who the economy people
are so nostalgic for the early areas
with strong unions and predictable wages
and factory jobs but you know that was
also the era of double-digit inflation
18% inflation if you could pay the rent
this year you didn't know whether you
could pay it next year cuz it it could
go up by and you kind of forget about
those days long lines around the block
to their gasoline the fear that we'd run
out of heating oil and we'd feel freeze
in the winter you high rates of poverty
among elderly people that have been
brought down by Social Security so are
just a commentary should look back you
know not ancient history but recent
history yeah what are some of the other
things that are that are hopeful right
now are there other markers in society
or
in science or politics are there any
other trends that you're seeing right
now that you think are leading us to
some yeah positive places well often you
get pleasant surprises when you actually
look at trends instead of headlines
mm-hmm and you and I were talking about
just off-camera about a recent survey
that showed the contrary to the fears of
a Millennial Generation being intolerant
of free speech and then for that matter
the society as a whole and especially
university campuses actually this course
this new study anyway you actually plot
the data we ask people should people who
are espousing controversial beliefs at
least be able to save them it's actually
been going up it's higher among the
college educated than the less college
educated it spans a range of
controversial positions it's true for
Millennials as well as baby boomers and
so that what I myself even experienced
as I kind of dread and foreboding about
a whole generation being intolerant of
competing views turns out to be probably
overblown there are lot of examples like
that and there are other positive
developments I mean the high school
students protesting are ridiculous gun
safety laws that kind of something that
we couldn't have predicted so recently
the the me2 movement has had a lot of
excesses and you know I think that
there's much to criticize on the other
hand it's not okay for women to be
preyed upon by their bosses and that has
suddenly become an issue and probably
the society will on the whole change for
the better because of it I wasn't
planning on going here but since you
mentioned it what would it be a
humanistic enlightened way of looking at
guns right now oh yeah
well some of it has to start with with
good data because a lot of our
stereotypes of just you know may be
right might be wrong you know on the
right they believe you have concealed
carry laws then that will reduce crime
on the left there's if we control guns
that will reduce
homicide so we got to be humble and try
to get as many studies as possible to
know what will really make a difference
and what won't but in general the idea
that that we're better off if we're we
individually are not the kind of judged
jurors journey and education er right
that one of the great advances of
civilization was that you outsource
justice to a disinterested third party
namely the court system race and that
the idea that safety comes from
individuals defending their interests
with guns is will in fact almost
certainly has led to high rates of
violence do you fear though that we
couldn't would that we often give too
much power to the state I mean I think
in in some areas we do but I think the
idea that people should have guns so
that they should resist the the
government you know the kind of David
Koresh and Idaho cults that is a
terrible idea the idea that we should
resist the government with with guns I
mean that's what they do in you know in
Congo Somalia we have this thing called
democracy so if the government becomes
too repressive we speak out against it
we vote we petition we form
organizations the idea that we're gonna
shoot back at the police I mean that
that's nuts
yeah what do you think of the state of
our democracy in general because I think
we're breaking off into these different
factions now where I mean I think some
people genuinely think that you know
this hashtag resistance that were under
this horrific authoritarian regime we
think we don't even have to get into
trumpet specifically if you don't want
but what do you think of just sort of
the the the systems that are in place
the branches of government all of the
the documents that founded this are they
doing all right at the moment so so you
know there are a lot of we by any
standards of world history we live in
fantastic freedom yeah I'm you know I
could say that you know Trump is a [ __ ]
and he's a fascist and I don't worry
about being put in jail and that's a
real something to take yeah not to take
for granted if I said the equivalent in
Turkey I would be put in jail or in
Venezuela
is that a little bit of the short memory
on some of the things you need to know
history because I think that all the
time I see these guys all the medians
it's amazing yeah I can say whatever you
really can and we should not take that
for granted it's partly history but also
partly comparisons across countries and
then history remembering fascism and
communism and looking at regions today
like like Turkey and Venezuela and
Russia there's that it the what's not so
healthy is like gerrymandering that
obviously subvert a subversion of
democracy the effects of lobbying and
campaign contributions from the the
wealthiest that can't be a good idea the
fact that our elections dragged on for a
year and depends so much on on a cache
is a problem and there are government
bureaucracies that have gotten too big
and too too many regulations that don't
actually do anything beneficial I don't
think that means that's a call for just
reducing regulation you know that with a
meat cleaver because some regulations
really have done done good we've got
cleaner air we've got less poverty but
we should at least analyze what
government programs are cost-effective
and which ones are just a nuisance and a
drag yeah and even having that
conversation then gets people crazed
where I personally I come from it from a
little more of a libertarian perspective
and I would usually say that these days
we've got people like Alan musk that can
get us to Mars and that can help clean
the environment and green energy and all
of those things where I know there's
just another set of people that think
well we just can't leave it to the
industrialists we have to leave it to
the government that's at least a place
where we can have some respectful yes
agreement that's a that's a great place
to that's the conversation we should be
having and I my view is that there has
to be a mix of policy and regulation and
private enterprise i and and all and
with all the creativity and innovation
and bottom-up diversity that so an
example would be one thing that the
government can do and that private is we
can't do is put a price on carbon
emissions this is a position that both
left-wing and right-wing economists
favor but having done that been the
private sector can come up with a
technology to reduce co2 and it
shouldn't be up to the government to say
this this company is the one that we're
going to support right and that's where
the the free market really does a better
job but having that that discussion and
and I think libertarians deserve credit
for raising an issue that people on the
Left just don't even think of like just
because you have good intentions and you
have a program with the goal of
achieving some good doesn't mean it's
gonna work well yeah total waste of
money well that's what I think so much
of it is it sounds good it all sounds
good we want the government to do all
these things and then we know that in
practice often although you've laid out
a case for some of these things that
actually do work cleaner air here we're
in Los Angeles the air is cleaner it
really it had a lot to do with the
government for sure so I absolutely
acknowledge that but to me it seems like
so much of it feels like it's it sounds
good let's just sort of hand it to the
government and then you end up creating
a whole series of other problems that
are from fiscal things to all sorts of
other things yeah you know I think
actually in some ways liberals have been
their own worst enemy in not being
willing to have that conversation and
almost like the platform is if you
support government programs you're a
good person if you post them you're a
bad person
yeah whereas the discussion really
should be which government programs make
us better off repay their costs clean up
the air reduce poverty which ones are
you know boondoggles or bureaucracies
and that way
even the people who are liberals could
at least have some ammunition and say
well don't don't kill that program it
actually works yeah
and I have in the book a graph of the
environmental quality since the EPA was
initiated in 1970 by Richard Nixon as it
turns out and the population is
increased by 40 percent GDP increased by
two and a half we've driven twice as
many miles but air pollution is reduced
by
sixty percent so and that almost
certainly wouldn't have just happened
with market innovation because there's
just no no one individually has an
incentive to not pollute that's the kind
of thing where governments can make a
difference
likewise poverty there are certain
measures like the Earned Income Tax
Credit which is a kind of negative
income tax where almost everyone who
right and left to examines it says
that's a government program that really
worked it's kind of cheap it's automatic
and it really did reduce poverty in the
lower middle class and working poor and
we need to have that discussion so that
the Liberals for that matter can say
well this program works don't cut it
yeah they don't think but even they have
kind of disarmed on the often on the
evidentiary debate and just made it
moralistic yeah I think that's what so
many of us that I would include in this
new group have you heard this phrase
intellectual dark web has this happened
some across your desk yeah I mean do you
do you sort of catch what I mean I think
that I don't know who is to say what it
is or who is in it or whatever but it
strikes me that you're sort of one of
the people that's right there it's just
people that are all coming together
because we're just trying to get a
little bit of the answers here which
really is what this is about
yeah and the way Jonathan Hyde calls it
is viewpoint diversity that it's a it's
not pushing a particular ideology but
it's getting a set of ideas out there
that don't have to they have to struggle
they don't they don't get a pass the
whole point of mentioning them is that
okay now now attack them see if they
survive is there a piece of America
right now or or I guess we could say
this in the West in general that our
freedoms have gotten so good actually
that we can't really figure out what's
bad so for example like during the the
whole debate over the football players
kneeling for the anthem I was watching
people you know everyone's just
screaming about everything and half the
people hate Trump half the people say
the football players are anti-american
than half the people turn it on the the
owners of the teams but I tried to lay
out a case that actually the entire
thing worked the way it was supposed to
in a free society Trump said something
but he didn't whether you agree with
what he said or not about mocking the
players he
try to pass a law about it so yes so he
exercises his free speech it's important
to recognize that that's he has that
right to if you had tried to pass a law
that's a different thing the players
could either kneel or not kneel they
might have to deal with the
repercussions of that the owners could
decide whether they wanted to keep those
players on their teams or not the fans
could decide if they wanted to not buy
jerseys or not or not attend games but
to me it was actually like a puzzle of
freedom actually working and yet every
day for months
people were screaming that this is you
know that this is the tyrannical and
regime and yeah and everything so
horrible does that sort of jive with you
that that we've gotten to a place where
we don't our freedoms are so great that
we're making these these mountains out
of things that that are important to
talk about but yeah I think that's a
good that's a good analysis I mean I
think it's a it's a way of appreciating
what other countries would would die for
I mean you just couldn't have that you
know football players or soccer players
kneeling and you know in Turkey right or
chest government policy I mean they'd be
in jail yeah Turkey one of our ala you
know you ought to use air quotes
yeah but yes I think sort of a good
point yeah yeah so before we finish up
here give me give me a few more things
to just feel hopeful about because I
think that really is what you're you're
trying to show people that there's so
much goodness right now and let's not
lose that yeah well here some some
heartening facts the the Flynn effect
that IQ scores have been rising by three
points a decade for almost a century
something incredible as it may sound
yeah this is a really well revived into
that one a little bit I spent too much
time on Twitter certainly the fact that
extreme poverty has been plummeting I
think is one of the greatest things it's
ever happened I mean literally from
seventy five percent reduction just in
30 years in global rate of extreme
poverty and the rise of literacy ninety
percent of the world's population under
the age of twenty five can read and
write and there's almost perfect parity
now between girls and boys that's
encouraging
diseases infectious diseases are are in
decline malaria tuberculosis diarrhea
and we vanquish smallpox just sent it
off into the the the into ancient
history it's in the
longer disease we may do the same thing
with polio with guinea worm is terrific
progress being made the and values of
toleration and what I think we'd all
agree are progressive values such as
toleration of homosexuality of women's
equality of the right to get a divorce
of political participation those have
believe it or not all been in in
gradually increasing every part of the
world even in the most politically
backward part of the world namely the
Middle East to North Africa there's been
an increase with especially when you
compare generations when the younger
generations are much more open and
sympathetic to liberal values than at
the older generation and there's a
widespread allusion
everyone thinks that everyone else is
more reactionary than they really are
people say well I'm kind of progressive
but everyone around me that Canaries
right there's a huge gap in how tolerant
people really are and in how tolerant
they think everyone else is yeah it's
really interesting alright so so in
summation we should feel good about for
the future but we have to fight for it
right we we should be recognized what
we're in danger of losing we should
recognize what we've accomplished as a
kind of impetus to do more Steven Pinker
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
for doing mine thanks for having me and
for more on Steven check out his new
book enlightenment now the case for
reason science humanism and progress
which we've linked to right down below
[Music]
you
[Music]